how did you develop your sense of story
you know because just because you want
to be a director it doesn't need you
know how to tell great stories so so how
did you develop this skill I think that
first of all I screen films I have an
eight millimeter projector and I get all
the great classic Hollywood film
directors you know Billy well during all
the rest of people that I admired and
and I just watched and learned from
watching other people do it and the same
time that I was doing that of course I
was directing in live television so I
was getting practical experience but so
I with the combination of experience and
watching other directors how they did it
I I developed my skills as a storyteller
I was very lucky to have City Newman as
my mentor and he would always say for
exact number will give you example one
thing to jump said in my mind there was
a scene where a middle-aged woman has
been terrorized by her mother and made
it regular trying to impotent as far as
men are concerned if you know what I
mean in relationships up she dies and
she sat in the chair that her mother
always occupied and delivered her income
iums to her daughter and I thought there
it is the image of her sitting her
mother's chair would be sufficient to
communicate and city center a Teddy neck
you're not getting the full value of of
it his tomb it's just an ordinary
ordinary bread and butter garden variety
medium shot now you've got it we should
after her four hands grasping the thing
but same time she's Fred of her eyes it
so you've always taught you know me so
yeah you're absolutely right first and I
then delete then we did it so the Sun or
communicated both her excitement that
are here becoming like her mother and
and her all the bad experiences she's
had with
mother Sonia vote by sitting the charity
from which she always delivered the bad
news so that was the kind of thing that
you you know you taught me
you